good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to commit
over to you Vince Lombardi
[Music]
I've been around high-performance people
all my life and really from all over all
Mountain element I've made it my mission
my purpose to study these people people
all walks of life people in military
people in government world-class
athletes great coaches people a private
sector such as a lot of you and I've
started with a thought what do they do
when they're at their best it's my
intention to see mean to hold up for you
a mirror a mirror that you can look into
and examine for yourself the breadth and
the depth of your goals and the
commitment and the discipline and the
perseverance you bring to the pursuit of
those goals it's my intention this
evening to create within you a little
dissonance a little disharmony a little
dissatisfaction which is the essence of
motivation so the balance of the evening
you begin to ask yourself some hard
questions and maybe you'll be satisfied
with the answers and maybe you won't
I'm not going to tell you anything you
don't already know just totally
representative little differently
perhaps in a matter that you haven't
seen or heard before
now you may sit there and say well
there's nothing new come on not the same
old same old not the same old
motivational stuff where every time we
come to a meeting like this well let me
ask you a question how many guys have to
take to get down away you'd like to be
at just one the one you stick with how
many times you have to reorganize your
office your desk your approach to your
business your profession your career
before you begin to see some of the
results you'd like to see just one but
when you commit to and stick with and
how many personal growth programs do you
have to take on before you begin to see
some of the changes in your personal
life you'd like to see just one the when
you commit to and discipline yourself to
stick with most people don't get the
success that they're looking for because
they don't commit to doing the work
again if you look at any major
successful person you look up to in any
field the people who are your own role
models people you want to emulate people
you want to be like they got there
because they committed to the plan they
took action every single day on that
plan too many people get started on one
thing and they lose interest in it or it
start to get hard until they jump to
another thing and they jump to another
thing and they jump to another thing and
because they don't take consistent
action because they don't commit fully
to the plan and they don't have the
success that they want to have because
anything that is worth doing is going to
get hard starting the business is really
hard you know losing weight is hard
putting on muscle is hard all the
important things you want to go out
there and do at some point is going to
get hard and what most people do as soon
as it gets hard is they quit and they go
look for a shortcut down another path
because that path is going to be way
easier than what you're doing right now
as soon as that path guitar you jump to
another path which is also you think
there's going to be easier but if it
gets hard you stop and that's what most
people do with businesses they start a
business it gets hard they go do
something else it gets hard to go do
something else
is what they do with diet they start a
diet it gets too hard that didn't work I
gave it two days and didn't work and
give it a week it didn't work they quit
they go do something else it doesn't
matter which diet you stick to for the
business as long as you're passionate
about it the one that's going to work is
the one that you commit to and take
daily consistent action on if I look at
my youtube channel it started to explode
and really grow when I committed to it
more fully at the start
I just had a channel you know I just
saved the name I was posting a couple
videos answering some questions but it
wasn't until I took it consistently when
I said okay I'm going to do regular
videos from once a week to once a day
twice a day the three times a day go
back on my channel not to me see the
growth starts to happen and that's going
to happen in every area of your life
another business decision and every
personal decision when you commit to
following through and you take
consistent action on it that's when you
start to see results so the question
today is I'm curious what are you afraid
to come to in your business or in your
life what's almost there but you're
afraid to take that final step and go
all-in and commit leave it in the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Javier Monte from hello talents
calm Javier thank you so much for
picking up a couple of my book your one
word I really appreciate the support man
and I hope you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I will see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press oh
oh
all right so keep me go
I looked at the odds you know but like
how am I even going to break in to this
business right all the good parts you
know if you as an unknown actor to get a
great role you know every every other
actor has to pass on it right every
other actor has to pass on it and then
it gets opened up to you and thousands
of other people like you right
and you all go and you know there are a
few parts like I was looking at the you
know a big part when I was when I was a
young younger was a primal fear remember
that movie with Richard Gere and Edward
Norton got the part as everyone passed
yeah I mean so that part became open
every young actor knew it I mean we when
I paid with money I did not have to take
dialect lessons you know hired a dialect
coach because the kid was you know his
alter ego was from Kentucky and he was
from somewhere else and I didn't I had
never been to Kentucky and so you know
every knew that that was it you know
that was going to launch somebody there
just weren't opportunities you know and
and so courage under fire was one of
those roles that was small it was really
only it was two scenes right I had two
scenes with Denzel and then the rest of
it was I'm the medic and I'm you know
you know Tim Guinea an actor who I love
who's in promised land actually is like
bleeding out on my lap for so for six
weeks we're in El Paso and he's like
moaning and I'm just sitting there and
I'm like I don't think the cameras on us
you know food it was it was a really
thankless job for both of us except for
those two scenes that I had with Denzel
so I had two days of work on that movie
and so I went well what do I do you know
it's a it's a it's told in flashback so
let me see how can I change myself what
can I do the guys supposed to become a
heroin addict okay well so what do I do
to make that seem like it happened and
the only thing I could come
which was a to lose as much weight as I
could and then put it back on as fast as
I could to go do the flashback stuff and
so that's what I did
I heard that wasn't good for your health
like your doctor was about terrible you
know it was bad it was bad because I
didn't you know I asked I asked them for
a nutritionist which was probably $1,500
at $2,500 and and they said no and you
know they I don't think they in their
defense I don't think they really knew
what I was going to do you know and
they'd probably have requests like this
all the time and I think their vanity
requests but it was a serious request
and and they turned it down and so I
went to a we had a friend we knew a guy
who was also a he was he was all he was
Austrian I mean funnily enough he was
Austrian and he wasn't he was trying to
be an actor but he literally because he
was offering he had Arnold's accent and
he was a former bodybuilder so he was
really aiming at a small bull's eye you
know but because his spot was really
taken by somebody but he he put me on
his program that he would do for
bodybuilding shows but they would do
that program two three weeks out you
know they would do this really kind of
reckless thing when they're when they're
just me you know and and so those guys
walk on stage and like you could push it
they look strong but you could you could
knock them over they're really suffering
at that point to kind of leech every bit
of everything out so that the veins and
the muscles pop out so so I did it for
like three and a half or four months
which is just too much you know too much
in it and it and but at the same time
you know it worked it worked and you
know when I got the Rainmaker a year or
so later coppola said that he'd seen
birds under fire and and that that made
a big difference and finally not it was
Edward Norton and I who were going
against each other again for that and
and and the courage under fire pushed me
over the edge and when I met I met
Spielberg later and he looked at me and
he said what you know and I'd put myself
on tape for Saving Private Ryan I never
anything I don't think tape ever got to
him casting director maybe looked at it
chopped it you know and so I thought
he'd you know seen it and he said well
you know what do I know you from it I
said I put myself on tape for him and
because no I didn't see any tape here's
what movies have you been and I said I
was in a movie called courage under
fight because just me you know I turned
to my wife when I saw that movie and
said that's the exact guy I want for
Private Ryan I just wish he wasn't so
skinny so I feel like I read a interview
at the time that said like you couldn't
even kiss your girlfriend cuz you could
taste potato chips on her lips the oil
from them ya know I mean it get it went
people who have those you know disorders
I got it I totally understood it like if
you want to be it because there I just
told myself I can't allow anything
there's no no compromising none like
because the second you open that door
you know it's a slippery slope and I
just what I wanted to look back on it
and go I did absolutely everything I
could I have been working my whole life
and what I did understand by being
determined to chase something by being
committed to it and what commitment is
completely understand true to what you
said you were going to do long after the
mood that you have said it in has left
you see people saying commitment is
saying yes I'll do it on the days when
it felt good but I had been committed to
everything that I ever started in my
life and I never stopped and I never
quit it and so by being committed to
everything that I started I finished it
it built a certain type of spirit it
built a certain type of mentality it
built a certain type of individual and
so now I couldn't quit even if I wanted
to I couldn't lay in the bed even if I
wanted to I couldn't stop even if I
wanted to I had too much sweat equity in
my life and everything that I was doing
because I understood my existence wasn't
about me
I went from me to we a long time ago I
understood the process is more important
than the product it wasn't about the
outcome for me once I made it to the NFL
or not that was inconsequential and
God's plan for my life but I was going
to fall in love with that process
because I understood by falling in love
with that process it was going to turn
me into a machine